of the 16th of september
as usual um well first of all i would
like to
welcome council ratican to the committee
um i will go through the names as usual
i am aware there are some apologies
uh but that will come up in that item
agenda
so if you're here please say so um
councillor alban yeah
counselor bathroom here chair counselor
coleman cook
here chair councillor curry here chair
councillor dennis councillor duckworth
councillor ghana i'm here chair
thank you councillor hart
councillor keane
councillor keane councillor raskin
here chad councillor scott
councillor taylor
councillor right hey chairman and of
course
myself uh thank you members
i am here it's councillor duckworth
thank you rose thank you
time no thank you uh
right a few points as always that i have
to read out to you
if you have any technical differences
during the meeting then please
contact democratic services the officer
on call who will attempt to assist you
today
is charlotte her number is 507
193 her number will be included in
the top of the chat box i will ask
participants when you are not speaking
please mute your microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone
who is listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on for a
participant who has been granted
permission to speak
to gain permission again put your name
and just put your name there and i will
come to you
when the other person has finished
speaking
with everybody present please ensure
that the mobile phones are turned to
silent
and they're not used to make or receive
phone calls whilst
this meet is in progress please also
refrain from checking
emails or conducting other business and
ensure that you are
in a quiet room free from distractions
for the duration of the meeting
uh please note that this meeting is
being live streamed
for members of the public and following
the meeting
the recording will be available on the
council's youtube
channel members requesting
to speak under procedure 20.1
we have councillor bob bayford has
requested to speak under agenda
item 4b are there any other members who
aren't on the committee wishing to speak
on any item
if they are out there could they please
say so
okay thank you members uh public
speaking
the following applications have been
reserved for public speaking
will plea members please note
following items on the agenda
and those items are gender item 4b
and agenda item 4 d
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
i have received apologies from council
dennis
hart scott taylor
for whom councillor rozewski is present
are there any other apologies please yes
chair
apologies from councillor keane thank
you
are there any declarations of interest
agenda item 2 yes please chair
i would like to declare an interest on
item 4b
um 158 percy avenue please
thank you counselor bayford um on that
um obviously it's difficult to ask you
to go out of the chamber
in this in you know the way we are at
the moment but i think it's fair and i'm
sure i will be corrected if you
obviously mute which you normally do yes
and
not listen to the debate uh
and not participate and not participate
at all thank you
yes thank you agenda item three minutes
the planning committee on the 19th of
august do members agree that the minutes
the planning committee
had on the 19th of august 2020 be
approved
and signed by myself could i have a
proposal please
i'll propose that chair counselor album
thank you
counselor can i have a second to please
oh second nature
counselor corman cook thank you uh do
you all agree
thank you very much thank you members
agenda item four uh scheduled planning
applications and public speaking
once again we're in that position
regarding site visits
um which i do know is being looked into
uh but at this stage we cannot commit
to site visits if there are any
agenda item 4b which is the planning
application for
approval of 158
percy avenue broadstairs i'm going to
welcome suki
to read out a statement uh from mr
pacey who is raising points of concern
if i could hand over to you sookie
please thank you chair
yes this is from josephine and michael
pacey
and they say sentosa
our property in 2nd avenue is the
dwelling directly behind the proposed
new build
in the back garden of 158 percy avenue
we urge you to consider the numerous
objections received from the local
community
and also provide a summary of our own
objections below
the majority of the bungalow including
the main front door
faces straight onto 2nd avenue and not
percy avenue
this will change the openness and sense
of spaciousness of both
our outlook and garden but also that of
second avenue as a whole
the application describes the plot as
disused land to the south
when it is actually the unkempt garden
of the current house
158 percy avenue is a rental property
has been so for several years and as
such very little gardening is carried
out
the proposed build is right against the
build line of second avenue
all other properties are recessed back
from the road
this is not in keeping with the road and
therefore harms the character
and amenity of the local area the
application states
the property situated to east of site
sentosa has no windows at second floor
along this elevation and no windows at
ground or second floor along elevation
adjacent to proposed site of 158
a this is incorrect our kitchen window
kitchen door dining room and lounge
french doors are all adjacent to the
proposed site
as well as the upstairs windows
the height of the proposed property is
too high
it includes a balcony and bi-fold doors
in the top bedroom
the application details a full-size
balcony
overlooking our property and garden
which is in keeping with the existing
arrangement
number 158 perth avenue which has a full
width balcony
at the rear looking over garden 158th
avenue does
not have a full width balcony there is
an overhang
over the ground rear bay windows there
are no railings on this overhang
and this has been the case for as long
as we remember
we have lived at sentosa for over 30
years
this is intrusive and an invasion of our
privacy
in addition the application states this
bedroom
will be a guest bedroom suggesting only
occasional use
this assurance is meaningless and cannot
be supported
there is a major traffic problem in
percy avenue
this is a year-round problem this
problem has severely
worsened during the fines now imposed
for parking
along kingsgate and fitzroy avenue
we cannot have a further increase of
vehicles in the area
the application states that the access
to 158 percy avenue
including refuge storage and collection
is presently
through second avenue and assumes that
this
should be the case for the proposed 158a
new build this is untrue
existing driveways are in percy avenue
and refuge is collected from percy
avenue
we feel this is trying to build a case
that the property is already
in 2nd avenue using facilities of
2nd avenue this is not the case
there is an established large hedgerow
in 2nd avenue
on the site of proposed build and this
is a magnet for local bird life
this adds to the character of king's
gate and this type of hedgerow is
rapidly disappearing this will be
threatened by the proposal
the application offers no economic
benefit to anyone
other than the applicant themselves
there is no evidence
that there is any need for any more
housing in this already over developed
street
and it is important that the character
of the area is maintained
it is a proposal for squeezing a
property into a cramped space
resulting in a negative impact on the
neighborhood
we would request that the planning
committee decline
this application
uh thank you sukeem uh speaking as wall
councillor uh councillor
bob beeford thank you chairman um thank
you members of the committee for
hearing me today um i should first make
it clear
that i live nearby to this proposed
development
i live in second avenue and as mrs
pacey's letter
said um this development is second
avenue not percy avenue
but i'm not really directly affected by
the this particular house but i think if
granted
it could set a damaging precedent which
could affect everybody in kingsgate
i will start off by endorsing everything
that mr and mrs pacy have said
and i won't repeat the detail i hope
that members have noted that i think it
was a very well put case
i would like to acknowledge that the
planners
the planning officers did ask for
a reduction in the bulk of this
development
uh which has been uh actually enacted
and has reduced the impact somewhat
but i think the very fact that it's been
asked for does reflect
that there is a sensitivity about this
uh particular development
and when we're talking about well the
size of whatever then
it's a question of of how big you know
that the original one was too big
the planning officer's suggesting
something small and then they've come in
with that
but i don't know if that's right i don't
think that it's an appropriate
development
at all as far as i'm concerned a
particular concern that the house is
being squeezed in
and that the ratio of garden area to the
size of the property
is significantly lower than is usual for
the area
this is contrary to the character of the
area where significant open space
between properties
is the norm and indeed the officer
report actually says
that in granting this it's subject to a
spacious setting being maintained
members that special setting amounts to
1.7 metres between the existing house
and the proposed new house
in real money that's just over five foot
i don't know
in what world that is spacious it isn't
in mine
[Music]
the building line in second avenue has
already been mentioned has been
completely ignored
so the property will stand out very
prominently
and it will very very much affect the
street machine
i think it's also regrettable that local
habitat is going to be lost here
now as point has already been made that
that it's a well-used
uh oasis for local wildlife and the loss
of it i think is really
to be deplored and i think it's very
again i don't understand how a payment
of 424 by the applicant will somehow
mitigate against this loss
i don't see that if approved
this applicant this application will set
a bad precedent
and every tiny piece of land in
kingsgate will become an object of
desire
for developers and i don't think that
that's good
so i would ask members to refuse this
application thank you for hearing me
thank you councilmanford i now will ask
the planning officer which i believe is
emma this afternoon to
give her report
do we have emma
i'm very quiet on me
sorry chairman yes thanks remember i
thought you were on holiday still there
for a moment
okay can you see my screen yep thank you
so this is the application site outlined
in red here so this is number 158
um percy avenue is um
along here and this is second avenue the
property
would be located in this area here on
the
on the corner of the site with an
entrance fronting on to 2nd avenue
just looking at this location plan you
can see the separation distances between
existing properties you can see on the
other side of the road there's a variety
of semi-attached properties
on this side of the road it's more
detached properties
and you can see that the gaps that exist
between them so whilst they are quite
spacious plots it is actually
quite tight in between the properties
this is an aerial photo of the site so
the application site is this area
here so it's currently a garden area
associated
with number 158 percy avenue um
the side extension of number 158 person
avenue would be demolished so the
so the application site is this garden
area but also includes this area here
where the existing extension is
and this is a closer view of this area
so
this is the property behind so this is
um sentosa
um who who have objected so you can see
this is again the um the location of
of the of the proposed dwelling and then
again another more detailed shots
showing the fact that this is an
existing garden area so again this is
the extension here that would be
removed in order to replace it with a
dwelling
and then this is just a view a 3d view
from looking from percy avenue towards
the site
so in terms of building lines you can
see that it is quite set back
from um second avenue to the property
but when you get to
sentosa there's a garage development to
the front of the property
so and when looking at the building line
um we are
looking at the front building of the
garage area so this is then a photo
looking towards the property so
then this is number 158 percy avenue
this is the extension area the two-story
extension needs to be demolished
this is again looking from percy avenue
towards the site
and you can see second avenue on the
right hand side of the screen
and then another view of that again so
you can see that there is hedgerow
around the site
there's no um there's no reason why they
couldn't remove that at any point so
although i appreciate there's been some
mention about ecology
as long as the the removal of the hedge
isn't carried out during nested season
there wouldn't be
anything that we could do about that and
then this is looking down towards second
avenue and now this is down second
avenue looking back to all the
application sites so this is 158
on the right here and this is the
application site here and now you can
see this is the neighboring property
sentosa on the right here and their um
garage projection
and then this is back in percy avenue
looking at the properties
um to the right-hand side so again you
can see a number of gary and
sorry bungalow properties uh detached
units
and then looking off to the left-hand
side of the application site
and you can see a main two-story
building some up to three-story
and all detached and then um this is
again looking towards the application
site which is this area here
so this is the existing block plan
showing the existing property
so again this area here is to be removed
and this is showing the existing
elevations of the property so again on
the right hand side here this two-story
element is to be demolished this is now
the proposed site plan showing the
dwelling so it's a two bed
dwelling um it is two stories but the
first floor is within the roof space so
it's a chalet
bungalow design amendments have
taken place during the application to
reduce the depth and height
um and the location of it to bring it
further away from second avenue so it is
significantly smaller than
the original submission and you can see
in terms of looking at the building line
it follows the front building line
of um 158 so i mean percy avenue is
following that front building line
and then into second avenue you can see
that the front
the side elevation or front really
because that's the front door there is
um set back
beyond the front elevation of the garage
of the neighboring property
um so again just looking again at that
space here this is where this is the
front elevation of
the wedding so again you see
the dotted uh orange line is the
original submission
so you can see how much it's reduced so
in height the dorm is reduced on the
side
and it's reducing width to set it back
away from the boundary in order to
maintain that building line
with the neighboring garage to the rear
and then this is the rear elevation so
originally there was a balcony proposed
that's now been removed so there's no
balcony as part of this so this is the
neighboring
property or 158 even um so that's not
part of this application
this is um the proposal with no balcony
at the rear just
one single window and then this is the
um side elevation that looks onto second
avenue so this is the
um front door and porch extension
and again you can see that the roof's
been barn hipped in order to reduce the
roof bulk and again you can see here the
reduction in the depth of the building
so all of this has been removed in order
to make it a much smaller more modest
development that then maintains its
space just set in
and then this is the other side of the
base on the left hand side with um a
small
um dormer set back from the front
this is a floor plan so at ground floor
level there's a bedroom at the front
with a study area and a large
lounge um kitchen air at the back and
then in the within the roof space
there's
just two single bedrooms again you can
see the single window at the rear
that would face the neighbor the left
hand side um window within the door mode
would be obscure glaze serving a
bathroom
and this is a street elevation plan so
you can see on the left hand side all
properties
are two story this now reduces in height
quite significantly
given the fact that there's a bungalow
on the right-hand side and
um bungalows in second avenue so it's in
keeping
with the the scale of development in the
scenario
and the setback as mentioned before is
maintained from second avenue and from
both
percy avenue as well so in terms of
looking at the impact on the neighboring
property
the as mentioned the balcony that was in
this location here has now been removed
also the reduction in depth of this
building means that the rear elevation
is now
no further forward towards the neighbor
than the existing renovation of number
158
so the impact from overlooking is no
greater than exists from
number 158 there's a single bedroom
window within the rear
elevation here which is looking towards
the garage area
of the neighboring property so their
main windows are in this location here
so it's not considered that whilst there
would be one additional
upper level window facing towards the
property it's not considered that the
impact would be any worse than exists
from
the existing property and the location
of it means that it wouldn't actually be
looking towards
the most um private immunity space of of
the property or where the main windows
are located
and so again this is just showing that
area here so this is the garage area
here and that's where the window
would be in this location towards the
neighbor
um so as mentioned um it is in keeping
with the building line so whilst it does
set back here it does follow the the
garage building line of this
location and is set back from the
properties here so it's considered that
whilst it's quite
a small site given the amendments
it's considered that the building will
sit comfortably within the site and
maintain that
spacious setting without any significant
impact to
to the neighbours or to the surrounding
currents of the area in terms of
highways you can see there's two parking
spaces provided to the front of the
property
um two parking spaces maintained for
number one five eight as well so there's
no highway concerns
um with that space and you can see that
um properties maintain quite a large
garden area
um and again um a garden area is
maintained for number one five eight
so on balance it's considered they is is
acceptable and that members
approve the application thank you
uh thank you emma i move that the
officer's recommendation
is adopted could the vice chair please
second
oh second nature thank you councillor
common cook
members over to you i haven't got any
names on my
screen at present
is anybody wishing to speak
yeah chairman come on let's have a
debate on this yeah not
gonna sit here and say and say nothing
no um
german i think um
i'm slightly concerned that sir why
would you want to demolish it to
a two-story part of your house to fit
another house in as obviously uh
that just seems a bit strange to me um
whilst i does whilst i do think it sits
somewhat nicely to be to be quite honest
uh within this uh particular
garden area of the existing house
um as i've said i just find it somewhat
um strange that
you'd knock a you knock a two-story not
a two-story part of your house off to
build another house so
um i'm just weighing this up really
really chairman i and uh but that's the
only thing i can think of to say at the
present thank you
thank you councillorman now i'm not sure
if i have something wrong on my screen
are there any other members and if you
can
indicate um there's no names coming up
on my screen
does any other members wish to speak yes
please
i'm just i'm so gone sorry thank you
uh yes please uh chair when looking at
the plan the site plan it looks quite
nice but when you see the actual
photograph
of the area it looks like it's jammed in
and it looks to me distinctly like over
development and i do
take on board what counselor auburn said
why would you knock down just to
build again it it just doesn't seem
right to me
thank you chair thank you councillor
councillor duckworth
uh yes haven't haven't looked at the um
offices presentation
i think um it looks as though a lot of
care has been taken
to to make it a much more modest
development and much more in keeping
with the surrounding area so i'm
inclined to um be in favor of this thank
you
thank you and my screen is working who
has ever
done something at the other end thank
you uh councillor ghana
thank you yeah thanks um
yeah i was going to say i mean i'm
inclined to
agree with um councillor coleman cook on
this it
does seem uh rather cramped
um i don't i mean i don't understand the
only reason well the only reason why you
would do this really is
to create a new new house and
obviously make her make some money out
of it but
it does seem rather cramped and i do
i mean i do we sort of glossed over the
loss of that
quite really quite large hedge that is
um
obviously alive with wildlife um
during nesting season and during the
winter as well
birds in and out of there and it's all
very well saying well we'll have to
we'll get
rid of it during the winter so as it
won't affect nesting birds
but years to come that will never be
never be replaced so i would quite be
interested to hear a little bit about
any proposals they might have for
a landscaping plan uh once they've
um completed this build how they're
gonna replace
that hedge if they are at all thank you
can you come back at all emma
um well there is a condition requiring
details of landscaping to be submitted
as a condition
so we would be considering that at a
later stage about what landscaping goes
back in
i mean it could be that the the
landscaping condition
um is even adapted if members feel
strongly about it to include
the need to actually have hedging as
part of the landscaping plan because at
the moment it's quite an open
landscaping condition that just requires
them to submit details but if we feel
strongly that there's an element of
landscaping that should be included it
could actually be
stated that it should show that as part
of the landscaping plan
um but other than that unfortunately we
can't protect
the the hedgerow that exists there at
the moment it's not
a planning um requirement to actually
you know require removal of the the head
they don't need permission to to require
the removal of the head so all we all
usually would put on is an informative
saying that
they should carry out the works during
the nesting season and other than that
that could be removed but yes we could
look at
ways in which they could get new hedge
planting as part of the landscaping
scheme
thank you emma um cancer raskin your
maiden spin
planning thank you very much chair and
the the development seems very cramped
um
and my other worry is obviously you know
in that area it's you know it's a very
nice area
and you know the the properties can you
know
fetch good money and will this
development then
leave the door open for other um
developers to look at and you know
buying single properties there and
trying to cram more houses in there to
get the sea views and
to get um houses in that desired area
okay thank you counselor again i can't
see any other
members wishing to speak um
i can't see you uh not all of you but um
if there aren't no other members wishing
to speak i'm going to put this to the
vote
if i may please correct me um let's say
i'm sure my screen is working correctly
now but
um we will go to the vote
and as usual i'm going to call your name
out members names
out and
a case of uh if you're for
against or abstaining
so i will start with uh councillor
coleman cook
thank you chair uh i'm against
council robin for over development
against
councillor curry against
councillor duckworth
council duckworth for
or against
four sorry thank you councillor thank
you
uh council ghana
against uh councillor rashford
again councillor councillorski
abstain counselor right
yeah against and myself i'm against
um right that has fallen
um now obviously we've got to decide the
way forward
um now i'm coming to the uh
and applications manager mr livingston
um as always yeah thank you thank you
chair
um so members have raised concerns about
um
common national elements of over
development cramped uh
concerned about the spacing between this
property obviously we're on a
a corner location which um obviously is
something that
the look at the various uh the various
images
and so it seems in terms of summing up
what members particular concerns are
um it seems that it's in relation to
uh the location and i would argue that
probably the design of the dwelling the
very fact that there is a dwelling in
this space
would appear uh unduly cramped
and incongruous um unrelated to the
character and form development
in the area which results in harm to the
character appearance of the
area uh contrary to qd02
of the authentic local plan um so i
think that is the sort of thing that i
believe would to encompass
the concerns of members um and and it's
whether or not anyone wishes to move a
motion
on those grounds that i've just outlined
and i can outline them again if a member
of wishes uh
sorry chairman i'm i'm happy to uh i'm
happy to move that chair
thank you councillor alban i i need a
seconder i'll say i'll second that
chair sorry phew there um
would you just like to read that out
again so then i'll put that to the vote
yes thank you so um so just to clarify
one
point um i believe and i may just i may
just have to bring in
uh uh emma if that's okay um we we have
a unilateral undertaking i believe
for this site is that is that right emma
yeah yeah we've got a signed yeah yeah
that's fine i just needed to just ask
attendances whether there were any
fans of refusal that we would be
required to put on to accord with the
habitat regs um
okay so just to outline the motion
before members
it's for a reason refusal that the
proposed development by virtue of its
location and design would appear unduly
cramped and in congress
on the corner of percy avenue and
2nd avenue unrelated to the character
and foreign development in the locality
resulting in harm to the character and
appearance of the area
not outweighed by the public benefits
because obviously that's what members
have considered the benefits of
providing one
new dwelling contrary to thanic local
plan policy
qdo2 and paragraph
127 of the mppf
uh thank you ian well we have a proposal
and a second uh i'll come back to
members
um uh you agree with that motion
well you need to vote on it chair go
through the individual sorry
all right thank you ann uh so i'll go
through your names again
if you agree or disagree or are going to
abstain
once again your names please so it can
be noted
uh council coleman cook agreed
council alban yeah for council curry
agreed councillor duckworth
against council ghana
yeah i'm four thank you account
rating
[Music]
and myself i'm four so that is carried
thank you ian
and thank you members
right um moving on to
you don't need any more information from
us here on that
no i didn't think we did uh planning uh
planning an application for approval
um which is one fair street
broad stairs um i'm going to ask uh
suki once again to read out um
a couple of lessons received uh the
first one
and correct me if i'm wrong sookie we
can do it the other way around but for
mr dads
that's correct chair it's uh um
a representation in favor of the
development so i'll read it out
thank you as officers have correctly
advised in their report there is no
conflict with local plan policy
the development consisting of new
housing in a sustainable location
and within the settlement boundaries in
terms of sighting and height the
dwelling on plot b
will be the same distance from number 42
as 42 is from 14. also
the ridge line of the dwellings will be
only 0.5 of a meter above
that of the neighboring property as such
the dwelling on plot b will not have an
overbearing impact on number 42
or cause any loss of light especially
since it will be sighted to the north of
42
similarly as the only windows in the
side of 42 server toilet and bathroom
along with the side kitchen door none of
which are habitable rooms
there will be no loss of privacy or
outlook
the density of this proposal will accord
with the density of other properties in
the vicinity such as the dwellings on
the diagonally opposite corner of fair
street
and properties in royal close and leaked
close however
at just under four dwellings per hectare
this density can hardly be regarded as
high
let alone out of keeping with the area
therefore there can be no
argument that more open space is needed
on the development
with regard to design the locality is
made up of a variety of dwelling types
and materials including
bungalows chalet bungalows and houses
finished in both tiles and slates
to their roofs this proposal which seeks
to address the concerns grazed at the
time of the previous submission back in
2009
is therefore in keeping with the
character and appearance of the area
in respect of highways both dwellings
would be provided with sufficient
off-street parking and turning
facilities
together with satisfactory access with
adequate pedestrian
visibility displays and sight lines on
the issue of drainage
neither southern water nor environment
agency have objected to the application
in any event pipes in close proximity to
boundaries will be addressed to the
regime
of the statutory party wall act
finally it is disappointing to note that
the town council unanimously raised to
make
no comment upon the proposed development
within their original submissions but
in response to the amended plans which
were aimed at improving the development
to accord with officer recommendations
they raised an objection nevertheless
the concerns they raised have been
addressed within the offices report
and through this presentation as the
proposal will represent
an enhancement of the existing street
scene the
officer's report is commended to members
who are invited to approve the
application
in accordance with the recommendation
and then i have a statement from frank
curtis
against the proposal do you want me to
leave it up there
yes please thank you he says
paraten ground says to safeguard the
residential amenities currently enjoyed
by the occupiers of nearby residential
properties dot dot dot
no windows shall be inserted in the rear
elevation
windows to the rear are constrained to
prevent overview of one flare split
but bedroom two of plot b has a
steepling window
with an unrestricted view of 42 wilkes
road
which includes those rooms where privacy
is most valued
this overlooking will be suffocating to
those in 42 wilts road which
is closer than one fair street but does
not
appear to be safeguarded in accordance
with parapen
character and appearance paragraph 127
of the
nppf policy qd02
and policy bsp9
states that proposals that conserve and
enhance the local character and sense of
identity will be supported
i suggest to the committee that these
proposals do not comply with these
policies
the fourth paragraph refers to three of
six immediate neighbors
however number three fair street
directly opposite west
39 wilkes road southwest and 42
wilkes road south are all conventional
bungalows constructed level with
or above the highway level therefore it
would appear that the proposed dwellings
would be out of keeping with these
closer properties transportation
the 2009 kcc highways raised
sorry in 2009 kcc highways raised no
objection to the location of accesses
to the site since 2009 the amount and
speed of traffic has increased
dramatically
particularly at school rush hour and
with regard to van movements
the junctions of wilkes road and fair
street is widely regarded as a hazardous
one
and is recognized to be an accident
black spot
it is most surprising to those of us
familiar with this site that
the proposed development is not
considered to result in a significant
increase in street parking
or harm to highway safety i would
suggest that the reverse is true
i believe that residents will be unable
to turn their vehicles around on site
and will ensure
reversing out and that will inevitably
lead to increased
street parking and restricted junction
visibility
my objections of second october 2019 and
the comments of other objectives remain
valid
mr livingstone's comments on an earlier
application are still relevant and
pertinent
this proposal for two large buildings of
unusual appearance on a single plot is
excessive thank you very much
suki i will now ask the um planning
officer which i believe is ian on this
occasion
uh to outline the report please
thank you chair
hopefully everyone can see my screen so
the application is for the direction of
two
two-story three-bed dwellings on
uh on the garden of number one fair
street so the site is outlined
in red it's undeveloped garden land at
the back of
number one uh the site fronts wilkes
road
fair street runs around as indicated by
the mouse and then goes off
down to the west then to look at the
aerial image of the site so this is the
site
in question and then if we look at the
an isometric aerial
image the site is in the center of the
image
as indicated here so this is the rear of
number one
number 42 wilkes road which is the
property that we've heard about
is to the right-hand side of the site
um from the image that we've got here um
i wanted to remember this image to
show the the character of the area uh to
be able to see
the relationship between this site and
the rest of wilkes road and this
area to the right-hand side of the
photograph
which is predominantly showing
semi-detached and detached bungalows
in the vicinity of the site whereas
on the north side of fair street here
as well as in the enclave in the
left-hand side of the image and also
back towards vale road
predominantly you're looking at
two-story properties and there's also a
development around the back of large
two-story properties
uh around uh to the uh what's the the
east
of the site as well so there is a mix of
of character in terms of the heights of
dwellings in the vicinity of this site
so looking uh directly at the site
number 42
is on the right hand side of the screen
you've got a bank of trees which is
separated from this development site
by an alleyway which is in the
background of this image
and then looking at the site front on
you can see the
the pitch of the two-story element of
number one fair street
uh in this area here um and then you can
also see the
the gable of uh number 42
wilkes road here so there's a this
boundary uh
treatment of two two meters runs around
and down the side boundary between the
the plot here and number 42
and then this is looking back down
wilkes um
wilkes road to show again number 42 here
and then the bun glows down uh the rest
of the road
and then looking back down towards the
site the site is
in this area here so you can see that
one of the enclaves of two-story
properties that's been built
in the background moving in then to uh
fair street so this is sort of directly
opposite uh the site
um where you've got the two-story
properties that ran along the north of
fred street there as well as a bungalow
on the corner
you can also see the pallet of materials
so you've got bungalows that are
predominantly brick
and then you've got other properties
that are also rendered
you've got roof tiles of different
colors and textures
as well and then this is a view
just looking from the opposite direction
so this is north
to south so this is the junction
of fair street and and wilkes road
um and then you've got a very prominent
tree that's
uh on the corner of the site which is
proposed for retention
as part of this scheme here is the
alleyway that runs down
the side of the site itself
and this is another view of the alleyway
and the tree
in question of the landscape at the
front of the site to be retained you can
just see the
the the back of number one fair street
here and this is the alleyway i say the
separation
with the landscaped area that's still
going to be present on the right hand
side
and then this is just a front view of
number one
fair street um so
as mentioned the proposals for two
dwellings so these two dwellings are
within the urban confines so the main
consideration on the use of this garden
land
uh for development of new dwellings is
the consideration of the impact on the
character appearance of the area
the impact on neighbours as well as the
impact on
highways and all other relevant planning
considerations
um so this is um one of the primary
elements that's been amended during the
course of the application the sighting
of the dwellings has been changed
from what was originally proposed as
well as the the scale of the
slightly reduced thing um so originally
the orientation
and site of these dwellings was at an
angle to
wilkes road that's now been um some more
uh regularized so it forms the same sort
of linear relationship that you have
with
uh with the existing bungalows uh number
42 and
onwards um members can see from the
the image that the the footprint of
these buildings
um is not out of keeping with the
footprint of the the bungalows
uh along wilkes road and immediately
adjacent to the site
uh but also these properties are are two
stories so the footprint's slightly
smaller
but the accommodation is is similar in
sort of scale
overall in terms of the square meters
that you'd get
so the form of development um is is
generally considered acceptable in terms
of the sighting
of these dwellings in terms of looking
at the actual design of the dwellings
um mention has been made of the the
ridge height of these units so these are
um two-story dwellings as we would
describe them the
main two-story element is this uh
the sort of gable feature that you've
got on both of the units
the rest of the building is primarily
chalet bungalow in design so you have a
front door window
you have accommodation and windows in
the gable ends
either side of the roof and then the
rear elevation
is just a pitched roof with relux
windows in it
one of the key elements of this scheme
as well is the fact that the dwellings
are set down
in the site so there is a change in land
levels at the moment on the site
and that fence that's two meters high
that we saw in the photographs
uh hasn't been dropped the other side
but there is proposed to be a drop in
land levels which is indicated
by the the dotted line on this plan and
we'll see
this in the sections that are provided
when we're looking at the individual
dwellings overall the scale of the
development is not considered to be out
of keeping with the area as mentioned
this is
between more of the two-story
developments with you and then the
bungalow developments so it is a sort of
a transition
between those two so we don't consider
that the scale of the development
would be out of keeping with that area
because it accords with almost both
forms of development you can find
in the vicinity whilst there is some set
down in the pavement uh
in the from the pavement level um we
don't consider that that
on its own would result in a harmful
impact on the character and appearance
of the area that there's some dwellings
that are set down
because they're going to be seen more in
the wider context of the two story
developments
that you have in the vicinity of the
site so in terms of the detailed
design i'm just going to go through
plots a and b
so plot a which is the property that
would be on the left hand side as you
look at it from
wilkes road um so the materials that are
proposed
are white render then with stained
timber cladding and slate roof
um whilst there aren't any um clear
examples of of the timber cladding in
the vicinity of the site
as i mentioned earlier the the texture
and color of materials that are found in
the vicinity do vary
um in and so therefore it's not
considered that there is a an overly
harmful or obtrusive impact
from having certain different materials
on this
actually some of the darker tiles that
are found in the area
and so it's not considered the materials
would be out of keeping significantly
with
those found in the area
um so this is the rear um rear elevation
of that property
um so you can see again the v-lux
windows here that is to avoid
overlooking into the private immunity
space that would be created in
the remaining garden of number one fair
street
uh this is the side elevation so this is
the internal side elevation that would
face towards the other dwelling that's
being proposed
then there's this elevation which is
facing towards that that bank of trees
and the alleyway
that members saw with the photographs
and then this is the ground floor plan
so you can see the existing trees that
are being retained as part of the
development
and you can see that there is a central
access point that's being proposed
uh that serves both dwellings um either
side
um with with a gate present as well with
obviously an area for
turning a vehicle as necessary uh
to try and ensure that the highway code
is followed in terms of
vehicles exiting uh you know in a
forward gear
and then this is the uh the second floor
plan uh the plans do match
for both units there's more significance
on the the plan for plot b
which we'll go through now so this is
plot b
so this is the the part of the
development that is directly next to
number 42
wilkes road so you can see the outline
of that property
uh on the right hand side of your screen
so you can see again the level
difference that's created from
the drop in height as well as uh up to
this thick black line
the the two boundary sorry the two-meter
boundary treatment that is present um
if we then go through those plans so
again you can see the change in levels
you can see where a retaining wall would
be needed because of the change in
levels that would occur
uh from the rear elevation so number 42
is now on the left-hand side
of this image
and then this is the side elevation of
the property which would face towards 42
wilkes road which we'll talk about in a
second when we're looking at the floor
plan
uh you can also see uh the parking area
here
and then a retaining wall uh before you
actually get down to the property so you
can see the land level change that's
being proposed
and then here's the other side this is
the elevation that faces into
the the site so this is an isometric
aerial image using google earth just to
show a bit about the relationship
between
sites so you can see that at the moment
there is um sort of some boundary
screening that is present
along the side elevation of the site as
well as having the
fence in place so one of the issues that
we've looked at is the relationship
between
number 42 and the proposed uh property
um because this is just the ground floor
layout against
sort of mirroring the relationship you
had on plot a
particularly looking at the second floor
window that would be present
here which um has a relationship
with obviously this property at number
42 and obviously in terms of overlooking
privacy that's one of the things that
the report directly is has looked into
in a bit more detail
so the windows are primarily due to the
heights that we're looking at
looking towards the roof slope of number
42
and the angle is restricted in officer's
view down
to the first sorry ground floor openings
that are present in the side elevation
of number 42 obviously restricted by
virtue of
a combination of the the two meter
boundary fence and also some landscaping
that's shown on the plan
as identified the windows are aren't
habitable room windows
um and and some until they do have
obscure glazing
because they serve a bathroom and toilet
um
and therefore because of the spacing and
also the height relationship
it's not considered these when this
window first floor would be
significantly harmful to the neighbor to
warrant
refused of the application by virtue of
overlooking
and the property the actual layout
doesn't
uh doesn't impact on the private most
private windows and immunity space that
you have
in terms of the rear of a dwelling that
you normally get in terms of the
immunity space and obviously the
the access down the alley is is not um
is not
usable amenity space in in quite the
same way so it is considered that the
relationship with number 42
is acceptable on on the terms of the
plans that we've got
in terms of the relationship with number
one fair street we've already mentioned
about the
the fact that you want veluxes in the
rear roof slopes to avoid overlooking
there is a window that is present in the
rear of number one
fair street at first floor level which
looks towards the rear area of
uh plot a however that's also being
considered in the report and assessed
and we've especially looked at the fact
that the immunity space uh and private
music space does wrap around the
dwelling because you have quite a a
significant two two meter high fence all
the way down adjacent to the alleyway
so they do have multiple private spaces
uh for play so we don't consider that
the relationship created there
is unacceptable uh there is also a
condition that's proposed
to remove permitted development rights
for um
for both of these properties to remove
the ability to
add further openings into the rear roof
slope of either property
again trying to safeguard living
conditions
of neighbouring properties
so just to touch on um previous history
of the site
so um for reference an application was
refused by the council in 2009 uh which
reference has been made to
um and this formed two dwellings a
garage block at the rear
uh in in this pattern so you can see the
orientation
is slightly different it's slightly
angled um the footprints of the
buildings
are slightly longer but also
the the dwellings were two-story
for almost the whole of the uh the
expanse of the footprint
um and and that was considered to be uh
too cramped in relation to
neighboring properties and into the area
um so overall um
the the development is considered to be
in accordance with the local plan
policies
the the dwellings that are created are
above the nationally described
space standards the immunity uh spaces
is considered to be appropriate uh the
development is
proposing to retain uh the the
prominent trees on site and there is a
condition that's imposed to ensure they
are protected during construction
there is also an archaeological
archaeology condition
uh for a watching brief to be submitted
and approved
so that archaeologists would be viewing
the development on site in case there
are any fines
that need to be recorded because of its
its positioning within broad stairs
and there is a unilateral undertaking
that is in place that secures a
contribution
towards the special protection area on
the basis
of the increased recreational pressure
from the addition
of of one dwelling so overall um it is
put to members
for the scheme to be approved um on the
grounds of the
with the safeguarding conditions
attached as well thank you chair
uh thank you ian i i move that the
officer's recommendation
is adopted could the vice chair please
second
or second nature uh thank you councillor
coleman cook
um i have two speakers at present uh
councillor curry
helen thank you cher i'm not a
massive fan of garden developments
but looking at this um application i
think
the scale and style of this looks in
keeping with the area
uh it does retain um garden space
and i i think i will support this
application
thank you thank you councillor curry uh
councillor ghana
yeah hi thank you yeah
um yeah i i as a one of the local wall
councils i called this in because um
yeah i had a number of number of
concerns
actually uh i differ with what
councillor curry's
just said i i feel actually
the style of the building is is totally
out of character with
with the meet the the bungalows in the
immediate vicinity
of the um new build um and it's
certainly out of character with
the um or certainly totally different to
the house
um one fair street in which the garden
is being built and lovely old flint
um house which has been there obviously
for a long long time
um so i am i am a little bit
concerned about the style of these
buildings and being
overlooked and being them out of out of
um character with the rest of the area
um one
thing i was familiar with the area i was
walking up there the other day
and that road actually is rather a
dangerous
road and there have been i know a number
of accidents
up there on that corner on that bend and
i don't think there's been enough
consideration
to um making sure the access to these
new buildings are are safe they're going
to add
to the um they're going to increase the
risk of further accidents on the road
and like i say it's already got a
history of accidents there
um so at the moment i'm i'm
not in favor of this application thank
you
thank you uh council raticam um i have
to agree with councillor curry um
when i look at the development it's uh
you know it's a very large uh
site and even with the development on
there it still
leaves a nice um big area for the
existing
property there um the proposed
properties seem a nice development as
well
so i will be in favor
thank you uh councillor owen
laura's here um writing something down
um
don't worry yeah i agree with uh
councillor curry and cat
councilloratigan um
i i think the uh this is different from
the last application that we've looked
at and in relation to the
the size of the plot where these houses
are going to be built or if
if it's approved um i haven't i have no
problem with uh
a different kind of design to what's
there
wherever throughout the country you'll
find different designs of houses new
houses coming in
where you know which is different what
what the existing is
you know do you want a 1940s design
still
don't know but um certainly not for me
um i'm i'm quite happy with this
and um and i'm happy to support the
application chair
thank you thank you uh
councillor bayford i'm glad you're back
with us thank you
chair um yes i think i generally agree
my first reaction was that
uh two houses on the site seemed a lot
but
on looking at the presentation it does
seem that they fit quite well
um i think they are not unattractive
and a little bit of variety it is no bad
thing
i'm very very pleased at the um
retention and protection
of the uh primary trees on the area
so i i feel also that i will be
supporting this
application thank you chair thank you
councillor bayford um
i don't see any other speakers
at the moment um so i can put
this to you members please my screen
seems to be working all okay thank you
now
so i'm going to put this to you once
again to vote
for those in favor uh if you can say
poor
against or abstain uh
councillor common cook for
council orban four councillor bayford
four councillor curry four
councillor duckworth four
councillor ghana against
council ratican thor
councillor zesky
paul thank you cancer right for
and myself that's time for uh
i believe that motion has been carried
i'm sure i'll be corrected if i'm wrong
thank you members
thank you emily that's been clarified um
that concludes the public speaking uh
for this meeting
i will call upon the clerk to read out
the remaining planning applications
if a member wishes to reserve an
application will they please
call out or put in the chat box that
they wish to do so
uh emily over to you
4a cloverly ellington avenue margate
4c 334
margate road ramsgate german i'll call
him fourth day please
for c okay
um which
is for c got my
gender
4c 4c4c
334 my road chairman if that'll help
sorry it does sorry about that yeah
um the officer who's reporting on this
uh chair if it might be worth um going
through
the item that hasn't been reserved for
public speaking uh sorry for
for debate um it might be worth calling
on emily to just call out the ones and
just checking that that can be approved
in accordance with the recommendation
yeah thank you thank you ian yes i
called on
emily to just call out the uh the one
that hasn't been
called in uh for debate
[Applause]
uh so so we just need a proposer and a
secondary for
4a could i have a proposal please
yes or no actually i think accounts of
coleman cook
and a second to please
thank you thank you very much i know
always go wrong
but uh uh you'll agree
i don't think we have to go through the
list on that right yeah
thank you members right back to
mr organ's concern is it you ian it is
me
yes chair i'll uh i'll pick you up
and and go through the presentation for
members let me just get my
screen up here
okay so the application
site is outlined in red so the proposal
is for uh the change of use
of the first floor and second floor
of three three four uh margate road
with a uh two sorry a single story but
at first floor level
rear extension and it's a change of use
of that property to
an hmo for up to five
unrelated individuals so
this is just a plan indicating where the
proposed extension is going to go at the
rear of
of 334 so this strip
um is a ground floor of commercial
properties with residential
of first and second floor so three-story
properties here
um so this is uh where we are so you've
got the the hair and hounds
on the corner here margaret road uh card
dealership opposite and then you've got
the commercial properties
along the frontage of margate road so
um it's uh it's the the news agents
property
um so the the property that's just here
but you can see the row of properties
and you can see this sort of uniform
style of property at first and second
floor level
so the access to the first floor is
actually around the back at the moment
so the moment
this is a maze net um so this
in the middle of the screen is is three
three four
um uh you then have next door
uh you have three three two uh which as
you can see
in the center screen i have got a first
floor rear extension
uh the proposed first floor extension on
on the application property would match
the rear extension of uh the one that's
next door so we'll just have a look at
that in a second
uh but you can see how the moment the
the access as i mentioned is at the rear
of the property so this is the existing
rear elevation so the application site
is on the one on the left hand side
uh and then here is with the first floor
extension so you can see the design
mirrors the one that's the other on the
next door's property
so the side elevation effectively builds
on top of the single story
element um here and then
same on the other elevation um so in
terms of the impact on neighbours if i
just quickly go back
to uh this image here
so this window is the neighboring window
and it's a very similar relationship to
that which has been approved
with the window on the other side
adjacent to the other first floor rear
extension
so it goes past the rear extension goes
past this window which is a habitable
room window
however it's considered that it doesn't
go sufficiently higher above
the height of that window to create an
overbearing
impact on the outlook from uh from that
particular window you can see how the
height of the
the actual property uh so the extension
is is lower and almost just above
uh the the height of the window itself
so moving through the layout that's
proposed so
uh 334 is at the bottom of the screen
there with 332
above so at the moment you have
the two accesses uh one that goes to the
the maize net above and then one that
serves uh the news agent goes out to the
rear yard
um so what's being added into the rear
yard is
uh some cycle parking that's being
proposed to serve the new
hmo and then at first floor
at the moment you have the lounge and
kitchen area and the bathroom
so those are remaining the same but with
the rear extension
then adding a bedroom and an additional
shower room
uh so one of the main considerations for
an hmo as members will be aware from
last month and previous months is
obviously the standard of accommodation
that's being
created and with with this type of
application we
uh get a comment from the council's uh
private sector housing team
obviously deal with hmo licensing to
ensure that um
the those licensing requirements are
also going to be accorded with
so you can see that the two bathrooms
that are being provided for the
five residents are on first floor
and that's to ensure that you're
according with the the licensing
requirements
uh for an hmo and then at the second
floor
uh three bedrooms effectively become
four bedrooms when subdivided out
um so you can see that it's the the one
bedroom is made smaller here and the
bedroom one has been subdivided into two
again those sizes are cord with the
licensing standards that are required
for the hmo to be licensed by the
housing team so that's another element
that has been
looked at um so with an hmo
we talked about this last month the main
issues are about
uh policy uh h019
which is looking at um the criteria for
housing multiple occupation
what the report goes through is that um
in this instance
the criteria that's specifically cited
um
that looks at whether or not there is a
uh
whether or not there is um i suppose an
intensification of this type of use
in a particular area that results in
an imbalance of the community and to
create
local disturbance uh the the criteria
that's put in there
when an assessment needs to be carried
out is that
um within uh 20 properties referred to
as dwelling houses in this instance
in the criteria uh when uh when more
than
uh five properties in a row of 20 change
to an hmo
it's something to consider as well as uh
when uh
when a certain percentage above within a
radius of 50 meters
is is changed it's something that needs
to be looked at quite closely
in this instance there are two other
hmos
in this row of properties um so
they are number one three two so the
property next door that has that
extension
that's already built on it and then a
property further up and i'll just go
back to the
location plan just to show members there
we go
so this is the property under the under
the application um
332 is here and then it's 340
which is just up here which is also down
as an hmo
um so the report goes through the the
considerations on this point
the the issue here is whether or not
there is a demonstrable impact on the
local community in terms of imbalance
the policy was originally uh adapted to
ensure that
wholly suburban locations uh don't have
uh
sort of uh undergo a bit of a
transformation obviously you then have a
confluence of these sort of uses more
comings and goings
that would then potentially create local
disturbance and imbalance
uh the mix of properties that you have
in the vicinity
in this instance it's the officer's view
that we are
in a a more um comings and going
location we're in on a a primary and
busy road the rear access
which comes off buxton road is used by
all of the properties along this
commercial
uh this these commercial units both to
access the upper floors
but also potentially to access uh the
rear
of the commercial properties so they're
always in our consideration quite a lot
of comings and goings that occur
in the vicinity so we don't consider
that in this instance the addition of an
hmo
would result in local disturbance um
over and above
the comings are going to go on at the
moment in this particular vicinity
um it's worth doing as well obviously in
terms of the this being an hmo rather
than
a maisonette with three bedrooms in it
um that obviously it is in a highly
sustainable location
uh margate road being said very well by
a bus route obviously you are
directly above a lot of local services
in terms of the convenience needs and
those sorts of things so we don't
consider
uh the lack of car parking uh that's
provided for this this dwelling
um oh sorry this unit over and above the
fact there's a dwelling there at the
moment
um to cause um a alarm or or a concern
with regards to the hmo
policy uh so overall it's considered
that
the proposal uh would be in accordance
with the local plan and as it would
avoid
it wouldn't result in our view in an
impact on local disturbance and also
we think the proposal would would
maintain a a mixed and
unsettled community um so it's
recommended for approval
thank you chairman uh thank you again i
move uh the officer's recommendation
is adopted because the vice chair please
second
yeah i'll second that chair yeah uh
thank you council carmen cook
councillor alban
yeah thank you chair uh i i called this
in for discussion
um i am extremely concerned actually
chairman
um you know there are a lot of comments
and going so let's add a lot more to it
um just listen to what uh mr livingston
was saying um
we've got hmo at 332 we've got a hmo
at 340a and now they want us
now there's another uh this application
for another housing multiple occupation
um it's it's clearly against
uh policy h019
in that we have got three this would
create three
within 50 meters and that is against
policy
ho19 i cannot support this at this
application chair
um and i'm hoping that my fellow
councillors will support me in this
thank you very much
uh thank you for your thoughts there
councillor duckworth
uh yeah i i'm sort of tempting to agree
with cancer album but um
what might help me is if you could give
me some information about the
plans for refuse storage
uh can you do that again
sorry my microphone's off um if you if
you give me
uh a second i will just find the
information required i've just got to
find
find the answer to that no problem
[Music]
um
um so i'm just looking through the
application details now
just to try and ascertain exactly the
position of the refuse storage
um what i would say is that obviously
what's been proposed
is that there is a cycle storage that's
been provided in the rear yard
um as and therefore it certainly seems
feasible that area can be used for
refuse storage
as well so refuse storage would then be
at the back of the property
in that rear yard rather than obviously
at the front um i'm just going to see if
there's any more details i can provide
about what's been submitted in terms of
what's been stated
on the application form so bear with me
just whilst i load this
up and see
what's been cited
um right
ah there we go yes it is it is entirely
my fault members bear with me
uh i will just present my screen to you
okay um so just to uh
just to point out so at the rear of the
property
uh where you have the outbuilding at the
moment and the gates you have the area
for
for bin storage here so on the right
hand side of the screen so it is at the
rear
right at the the rear of the property as
it stands at the moment and again
um this is where you have an existing
property
obviously an existing maze net that also
has you know
you know needs the same sort of bin
storage provided which obviously could
have
um you know three to four people in it
at the moment
and so that's that's the location of the
refuse store on that
okay thank you and um
counselor ghana
thank you yeah thank you
all right uh how you have to say i i
agree
with um councillor alban i share his
concerns
about the number of hmos
within this area and heze says it does
um exceed the threshold of h019
and i and i also know there are there
are already
a significant number of hmos within the
within the close vicinity of these
hmos in this row just up the road in um
on the
on the wimpy estate um it's
it's it's well there are quite a
significant number already
so i share his concerns um and
i'm i'm open to be persuaded otherwise
thank you uh council um i'm
again with my other counsellors um
i think there's already enough hmos in
that area
um and i won't be supporting
that
thank you chair uh yes unfortunately uh
you know i do
feel that hmos serve a very useful
purpose but
not the fact that there are so many in
close vicinity
there is there are more comings and
goings um more activity
and i think they need to be spread out
spaced out more so i'm afraid i
i don't think i can support this
application
thank you thank you thank you councilman
for cancer right
thank you mr chairman i must i i also
agree that
um having um seen what the
how the wimpy estate was overrun
i can see this happening all over again
so i won't be supporting this
application either
uh thank you um i can't see any
other people wish to speak
um so again i'm going to put this to you
members
um with your feelings obviously uh quite
strong there on some points
so once again i'm going through yourself
the names
uh if you're for against
or you are abstaining um
councillor common cook against
council robin against
against councillor curry against
council duckworth against
council ghana against
council rastigan against
councillorski abstain
counselor right against and
i am against it as well um i think i
know the answer there but i'll have that
confirmed by
emily and if i'm correct
i'm gonna have to come back to ian
thank you chair um so i think it's
pretty
um it's pretty straightforward
motion lost yeah yes i think it's pretty
straightforward in terms of the concerns
of members
specifically related to the policy in
question so
um may i sort of uh offer a potential
motion
for um a member to propose
um which would be um that the proposed
development
would result in a concentration of of
hmo uses in the local area
uh detrimental to the immediacy and
character of the neighborhood
uh contrary to policy uh h019
of the senate local plan 2020.
i'll propose that chairman
pointer council auburn i believe that
was councillor ghana the second
it was thank you councillor ghana
right you've heard the motion um if
members wish and to read it out again
i'm not sure if you do
i think it's straightforward nope
right i will go through your names again
regarding the motion that's been put
forward
proposed and seconded accounts
councilman
coleman cook for
council robin for
councillor bayford four councillor curry
four council duckworth for
council ghana four
councillor ratigan or
councillor zesky abstain
cancer right four and i'm
four as well so that motion has
been carried thank you members
um that does conclude
the planning committee meeting this
afternoon which i thank you for
a couple of points if i may um
uh before we disappear uh i'm sure
you've seen we've had the email for
the next planning meeting which will be
on two weeks today the 30th
of the 9th which i believe is going to
be um
you